[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia telluride
supper suite in Park City we're sitting
down with the team behind wander darkly
we've got writer director Tara Miele and
stars Diego Luna and Sienna Miller guys
thanks for coming in thanks for having
us thank you you know for the folks at
home why don't you tell them what is
this project actually about and what is
the genesis of it
sure wander darkling is about a couple
their new parents they're going through
a difficult time in their relationship
when they get into a pretty brutal car
crash so in the aftermath Adrian played
by the delightful Sienna Miller finds
herself in this state of purgatory and
is questioning everything about her life
and Mateo her partner tries to sort out
truth from fiction for her and together
they sort of relive the path to see how
they will navigate their future where
did it sort of start for you to write
this so my husband and I survived a
pretty bad crash about six years ago
we're fine totally fine but uh I was
quite concussed for a bit and we have
two little kids which also sort of
changes your sense of your own mortality
and I think we were like at my mom's
house at Thanksgiving that year and the
kids are crying and someone's fighting
about Turkey and I just was like we're
so lucky you know I was really
overwhelmed by this sense of gratitude
for the messy little lives like the
delicate and just the messy little lives
we were leading and I was very desperate
to share that feeling and Sienna and
Diego why don't you tell me what
attracted you to the characters of
Adrian and Mateo you know it was more
that when I read the script I had a
pretty intense emotional reaction to it
and I think if whenever that happens
you've got to look a little deeper at
why and and it probably means it's
something that I'm gonna want to explore
but I think for me personally the notion
of of spending the time to go back and
reflect and look at the beats of a
relationship that can be minor and
insignificant but where people just go
wrong that really landed in a beautiful
way it was it was a very moving script
it was an amazing piece and Terra I
thought did such a wonderful job and
then Dee and I have been friends for a
long time and have always wanted to work
together and this just felt like the
right thing
yeah it was it wasn't the character it
was the relation you know and and the
perspective you know the the tone and
the point of view of the script I think
it is a very smart way to look at that
relation and to look about love and and
it was a challenge you know as an actor
I saw an amazing challenge it was it
reminded me a little bit the work you do
in theater you know because there's
always this there's always this level of
consciousness there there is you're an
actor playing a character but there's a
character you're reflecting on his life
therefore kind of it's another actor you
know kind of thing so there's there's
these moments in the film that are yeah
very theatrical and I love theater and I
thought it was a great chance to do a
film that I haven't seen basically you
know and that doesn't happen often have
either of you ever been in like a rocky
relationship where you had to navigate a
life changing type event like this bumps
in relationships and I've definitely in
reflection of those moments been sad
that there weren't that nothing that
something wasn't examined perhaps as
deeply as it could have done I've never
had a significant sort of moment where
it was a life-or-death moment that then
caused that kind of reflection thank God
but I think we also need I do look back
so this suited me okay Tara I understand
that this film has some interesting
tonal shifts can you sort of talk about
that and how it you know fuses genres
yeah so I think when I was writing the
script I just didn't think about genre
at all I felt like I knew the story so
wholly and I wanted to create something
that worked in the way my brain works
which is very rarely in the present but
often sort of in the past or projecting
into the future and I think also with in
real life we have moments of humor and
moments of horror and moments of deep
drama and I think for me at all often
happens at the exact same time and
I very much wanted to figure out and
that was actually I think our biggest
challenge on set was but there has to be
this moment of lightness but like it
can't be ridiculous it can't be like
losing the emotion of the scene as well
and so Siena and Diego thank God are
like you know we're able to do these
hairpin turns where something is like
you know devastating and then suddenly
there's humor and then you know anyway
thank goodness they they were able to
figure out what it all meant
[Laughter]
this being Collider you know where our
audience is big movies that kind of
stuff I understand you recently directed
a couple episodes of arrow and yes yeah
I mean do you want to continue pursuing
you're trying to get like a comic book
feature you know it's interesting I I
quite like doing lots of different
things and I think as long as a project
has something that excites me and is new
I mean like obviously with wander darkly
I was like this is really hard and weird
let's try it I really live in that space
where I don't know if it's gonna work
and I love that space because that's a
really nice big question place to be in
so I'm living in that question right now
of like what is this next thing so I am
writing I'll say that much but um yeah I
I would love to have big resources to do
big stuff on a big stage and Diego and
Sienna both of you would make incredible
comic book characters is there anyone
who you'd want to play down the line in
the future I mean I always I had a soft
spot for Catwoman that ship is obviously
sailed but I would have loved to do that
I don't know I don't know if that ships
sail there every five years they reach a
40-year old yeah I'm into it
I'm trying to think I am NOT I'm not up
to speed on comic it'll be great it'll
be fun
I don't know I'm still waiting for the
the Latin American superhero you know
that drives in the beetle app yeah yeah
a beetle that flies no no I mean the
beetle the car a car like a taxi a
Mexican taxi that flies and then out of
it comes this Mexican super kind of
Gringo's like this
now the lovely Lynette Powell Taylor
produces and she's relating a little
thing called the Oscars in a couple of
weeks I feel like she should have you
guys come out as presenters together
you'll be open to that idea
I actually am presenting every award
it's just me welcome and presented the
Oscar just when I said I'm the only one
that's going to do it yeah we've done it
before
why not I mean we have to yeah it's
quite late notice thing I think we'd
probably know by now if we're presenting
it in her fair enough now Diego I owe
you an apology
what why because when you were cast as
Scarface I was a little skeptical I was
like those are big shoes to fill
I don't know if I see him as a drug
kingpin and then I see you play and
you're incredible on the show and I've
seen the entire second season we won't
it we won't get into spoilers I promise
but you know for the folks at home who
are fans of the show and can't wait for
it to return what is in store for Miguel
ángel félix Gallardo's assemble Oh
[Laughter]
well it's just the only thing I can say
is that it's quite scary because it's
getting really close you know it's
getting I remember that Mexico I grew up
in that Mexico and and and the names you
start hearing are still out there you
know and and and and they were well not
the real bad guys because I mean it's
not about good and bad but there's so
many people walking in the streets that
should be in jail these days making
decisions in my country and and hearing
those names is quite scary because yeah
it's getting close still doing that
Scarface movie no Siena I thought you
were wonderful an American woman Thanks
and the critical support was there but
the film kind of flew under the radar as
far as Awards recognition do you think
that the Oscars are kind of biased in
favor of studio movies with big
campaigns behind them I don't think it's
the Oscars necessarily I think so much
rides on when a movies released and
unfortunately how much money they have
to spend on print and advertising and
with a small movie like this I don't
think it should have come out in June I
yeah I I it's it's sad because that kind
of recognition does just move a needle
in a way that would be useful just keep
on truckin well it's a wonderful
performance so if you guys haven't seen
it definitely track it down um I also
wanted to ask you because I love the
loudest voice that is brilliant
so did you happen to see bombshell I did
what was your take on that movie as
someone who was in the other Roger Ailes
project I thought it was a different
take I am huge fans of those three
pretty phenomenal powerhouse women and
it was really interesting because it was
so different
ours was we obviously had a lot more
time to go deeper into him specifically
but I liked that there was a film about
the female more about the female
perspective they're both valid and
unnecessary and I think it's a good
moment to be having those kinds of
discussions about those kinds of people
yeah well it was wonderful and we're
gonna get to we have a few supercut
questions I'm gonna ask in just a second
but before I do I gotta ask about the
casting and or series can you sort of
give us an update on the
timeline of when things might get
underway shooting or for me you know it
has to be this year obviously and and
it's happening the writing at the moment
right it's pretty cool what up yeah it's
gonna it's gonna be fun and I'm excited
I can't wait to go back and look younger
alright thank you guys for coming in the
team behind wander darkly thank you to
the key of supper suite for having us
and stay tuned for more from Park City